thank you
yep
um we're going to start the proceeding
with a credit here
so this is an exchange for the prayer
that the last Council
head my pronunciation is probably going
to be terrible but I think it signifies
the building relationship that we're
going to have with monofinoa in the area
and as my pronunciation gets better I
believe the relationship with manafinoa
in the area will also get better
Nui
foreign
drawn the Supreme skewness to clear to
free the heart the body and the spirit
of mankind
suspend high above us I.E in heaven draw
together in a film
please be seated
so for future meetings with the
finishing of the karakia that is the
indication that the meeting is opened
do we have any apologies
no no apologies fantastic
uh any
conflicts of interest
nope
on 2.3
confirmation of minutes
do we have any questions uh regarding
the minutes for the inaugural council
meeting
held on the 22nd of November 2022.
uh councilor Stringer
um yeah to his worship
um on
note 9 adoption of community interests
register and appointment of the register
there was a question to you regarding
um
register of interest and update working
with them Council city council has
anything been progressed on that
page 20 yeah through your worship the
answer is uh no only because the
um where that
subsequent to this particular item just
discussed titwara the national
management organization for
local government managers have put out a
template so it's intention of Lorna
straith who was the Registrar of
interest to send out that template to
you in the very near future
thank you
any other questions regarding the
inaugural meeting
could I please get a mover that the
minutes of the inaugural council meeting
on the Tuesday 22nd of November 2022 a
true incorrect
uh councilor guardine and seconded by
councilor Phillips
and for the statutory meeting on the
same day do we have any questions
can I please have a mover that the uh
statutory meeting on the Tuesday the
22nd of November uh true and correct
councilor Dixon and second and divide
counselor Richard mcfer
thank you counselors
I have so on to point four I have an
urgent item and then I'll explain mine
and then move on to uh if there's any
others so I'm adding an urgent emotion
for an urgent item which we're going
between item 13 and 14 of a letter sent
by the matoda community board last night
requesting a change to the Charter
um regarding section
46a7 of the local government and
information and meetings Act of 1987. uh
the reason that this is not on the
agenda is that the letter was sent last
night following the matoda community
board meeting and the reason for the
urgency is that the agenda
that later on the agenda the meeting
schedules are being discussed
and I would believe that it'll be
counterproductive to set
meetings to then undo at the the next
meeting when we address
The Adjustment and the charter so I was
wondering hoping I could get a mover for
that motion
uh councilor Phillips and seconded by
councilor Reed
um I will circulate the email as well
I've got copies for everyone so I will
circulate that round
um so you can have a copy of that
um when we get to that June Dyson
what did you want it now
when we get to the agenda item cool
fantastic
is there any other late uh sorry
uh just putting that motion on the table
um
all those in favor
against
the motion is carried that will be added
at the end of the agenda are there any
other urgent business
right home moving on
the appointment of Deputy Mia
so with this agenda rice I'm given that
the attention on this item has caused
tension not only between counselors but
also the council and the public I feel
that is appropriate with the permission
of Stuart who I asked prior to this
meeting to read his resignation for the
public as a fresh reminder to councilors
as to why we're here and to for
transparency for
uh the public as well let me just find
that
so this was written to me on the 1st of
December um 2022 which is when we had
the workshop
do you have been your appointment of
myself as deputy mayor has been the
cause of a major division between
councilors with seven councils signing a
document asking for my removal
I know you have expressed support for me
through the whole way through this
difficult period however even if I was
retained in my position at the Statue
meeting on the 15th of December it would
leave the council deeply divided
we will need to work as a unified team
over the next three years as the council
will face a number of extremely
difficult challenges over this period
having a unified council is my Paramount
concern therefore I am tendering my
resignation as Deputy effective
immediately
I thank you for your trust you have put
in me when you offered me the position
of dip anemia regards Stuart MacDonald
so I think that puts into respect of
this agenda item moving forward with
those well pot words my support still
stays with Stuart and I would like to
publicly thank him for his time as
depedimia
with that being said I will not put
myself into another person in another
elected member through that challenging
process again instead I think it is
appropriate that counselors choose a
fitting deputy mayor that majority can
agree on finding the unity as we move
forward as Stuart very rightly put in
his letter of resignations
so with that being said
do I have any nominations for deputy
mayor
councilman McDonald
do I have a secondary
I'm happy you worshiped to second that
motion but in doing so I'd like you to
endorse the appointment also of Keith
havell so that Council can move on and
get on with the work of counselors
Representatives
thank you for that counselor
um yes sorry I probably should have put
in my little Spiel there that I I will
um standby whoever is put through his
Deputy mirror I believe I can work with
everyone around the table so whatever
nomination comes forward I will be happy
to work with them
now it's open for discussion councilor
Reed thank you Mr me
um Keith I'm happy to second that as
well after or support you in this
position I think it's lovely that you've
offered yourself to the mayor to do this
particularly as a first term counselor
but just in doing so would you like to
perhaps
talk to the meeting and the right payers
in general about where you see yourself
in this position
thank you and thank you for the
nomination and the second is
um
I think I'd like to to start off by
highlighting that the position of Deputy
Mayor is not a position of power I have
one vote around the table and the same
as everybody else
the deputy Mia's role is one of
responsibility
and I recognize that as being important
in terms of carrying out the duties of
assisting the mayor and the work that
he's doing
and I will do that with the energy and
to the best of my ability
the role of Deputy is mini-fold in terms
of providing advice to the mayor
providing a further link for the public
for counselors and for staff both to and
from them here in representing this
Council on a number of different
organizations both as the deputy on
those organizations and also at times
standing in for the mayor what is entity
coming in is this likely to be taken out
of our hands anyway like the decision
being made
uh can either staff member commit on
that
yes sir you worship yeah that's uh did
right once the if the three Waters
reform goes through the water entity
will act upon the director General's
directive and we'll have no involvement
in it
foreign
await the directive of the director
general of Health regarding
fluoridization of its drinking Waters
is there any other recommendation out
there or are we we happy to move
um that motion
happy to move that motion um could I
could I get a mover for that please
uh councilor Havel and a seconder
uh councilor mcphail
or all those in favor please say aye
against carried
moving on to a gender item number seven
is there any further comment from the
general manager of community lifestyle
services
worship there's a couple of uh points to
update the report
agenda item three point or report
paragraph 3.7
mentions the closing date of 30 January
it's been extended now to the 5th of
February so I'll just update that and
would update that in one of the
recommend on the second recommendation
on the top of page 28 so that the
closing date of five five February 2023
be amended